dans cet hôpital de vladivostok
cette infirmière s'apprête à injecter le
vaccin un vaccin totalement gratuit non
obligatoire fonctionnant en deux temps
avec une première injection suivie d'une
autre 21 jours plus tard je travaille
avec le co vie depuis mai j'ai vu
quelles pouvaient être les conséquences
j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux recevoir
une dose pour que mon corps soit prêt et
même si je la trappe
je m'en sortirai plus facilement j'ai
déjà vu des médecins se faire vacciner
par le passé et tout allait bien cela
m'a donné confiance
personne ne me forcez c'est absolument
volontaire des vaccins d'abord mis à la
disposition des populations les plus
exposées à la maladie médecins
travailleurs médicaux enseignants ou
encore travailleurs sociaux une campagne
de vaccination massive débuté le 5
décembre dernier à moscou et dont le
succès est primordial pour les autorités
elles qui ont renoncé un deuxième
confinement pour sauver l'économie du
pays une économie marquée par des mois
d'inflation entre janvier et novembre le
prix du sucre a augmenté de 70% les
pattes de 10% et l'huile de tournesol de
24%
autre indicateur inquiétant le chômage a
bondi à 6 3% en octobre contre 4 7% en
mars juste avant le confinement
printanier mercredi dernier
vadimir poutine a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
mais j'espère que la situation se
stabilisera à la semaine prochaine en
l'occurrence cette formulation ne me
convient pas du tout n'est pas de
j'espère vous de venir à paris ni
prochaine nous allons stabiliser la
situation chez vous d'autant que le
ministre russe du développement
économique
le président russe a chargé ses
différents ministres de mettre en place
des mesures d'urgence alors qu'il est
attendu ce jeudi pour sa traditionnelle
conférence de presse annuelle